time for nature the tagline for this
year's World Environment Day the theme
biodiversity more than 500 species have
gone extinct in the last 100 years
another 500 are on the brink
human-driven climate change is one of
the factors pushing what scientists say
is a sixth mass extinction industrial
production and air travel are some of
the main causes of the co2 emissions
causing global heating but the
coronavirus crisis has largely brought
them to a halt
the biggest drops in global emissions so
far came as a result of conflict and
three global recessions but some
projections say the current crisis could
lead to the biggest ever drop in
emissions more than all these previous
reductions combined still some experts
say it's not enough I think there is a
short-term gain you know like we're
seeing co2 reductions right now but we
need really a massive global effort to
solve the climate crisis and right now
we are gonna spend the next five years
you know focused on this pandemic and
responding to it which are five years
that we don't really have a society's
move out of lockdown the question is how
will they do that for nature
environmentalists will be hoping for a
more sustainable step into the future
more on this for joined by Neil King
from DW environment he's host of the
podcast on the green fence Neil does the
drop in co2 emissions we're seeing
during this pandemic give us any reason
to hope that we might be getting a grip
on climate change well first of all I
think it's very important that we make a
distinction here between co2 emissions
and co2 concentrations that's the level
of co2 in the air because even if we
have you know record drop in emissions
this year the International Energy
Agency is predicting 8% for the overall
year that's about 2.6 billion tons
that's a huge drop it doesn't mean that
the levels stop growing in fact experts
say we would have to cut human-made co2
emissions by 50%
if we wanted to initiate a trend
reversal here it's a bit like a bathtub
you know if you have to tap running the
bathtub the levels will still rise the
only way to actually turn things around
is to switch off the bathtub
switch off the tap only that
carbon-neutral economy and society will
get us where we need to be with
countries desperate to get their
economies going after this corona virus
pandemic isn't there a danger that
fighting climate change will be off the
agenda for years to come
well there certainly is that risk
because yeah the economic crisis were
facing the global recession that we're
in for millions of crops at stake
also the pandemic these are very
imminent threats for more concrete and
tangible to many people then climate
change but climate change let's not
forget is by far the greater threat is
an existential threat for mankind so we
have to get it on the agenda and I think
actually we have a window of opportunity
here because we have leverage with the
bailouts you know all these bailouts
that'll be drawn up to prop up the
system prop up companies we should use
this opportunity to actually extract
concessions from the companies who tap
into this money it's taxpayers money
it's your money it's my money and we
should get binding commitments that puts
them on a more sustainable track so
there might be some potential there but
the lockdown has already radically
changed human behavior patterns do you
think these changes could have an
impulsive implications for the
environment well yeah we've seen a lot
of change these past months with the
lockdown and unfortunately I'm afraid
that most of them probably won't be
lasting there a lot of people out there
who want to get back to the old status
quo rather sooner than later but there's
one aspect regarding mobility where I
think we have a chance to have an impact
on the environment and that is home
office we've had quite a few ability
study undertaken here these past few
months you know with the lockdown we've
managed to swing it even under very
adverse conditions even with home
schooling we've pulled off home office
in many sectors and if you think about
it that transport accounts for about 30%
of all co2 emissions in the EU and
three-quarters of that is down to road
traffic so if we could take commuters
off the roads by giving them more home
office possibilities they could actually
make a huge dent in
those co2 emissions and it would also
enhance work/life balance for employees
and happy employees are good employees
so I think if we made home office the
new normal
rather than the exception that would be
a great takeaway from this crisis Neal
thank you so much that was Neal King
there from our environmental desk
thank you even though co2 emissions have
slowed worldwide due to coronavirus
restrictions environmentalists fear a
spike in waste from protective equipment
which often ends up in the world's
oceans and seas the air is clean in
Paris with most airline flights grounded
and many people stuck at home
but the see is another story here off
the Mediterranean coast of France masks
and gloves are plentiful this is the
first sign of an advanced type of
pollution if nothing is done a beautiful
coast we know that as soon as it starts
to rain all the rubbish coming from the
gutters will end up in the sea and we
could see more in the weeks to come
plastic personal protective equipment or
PPE has helped millions of people to
deal with the pandemic it's allowed
businesses to reopen and travel to
resume and many people are reluctant to
give it up like here in Italy everybody
being very careful all of us travel with
our kid I'm in favor of face masks
I wear a double mask health authorities
around the world warned against reusing
plastic PPE the risk of infection is too
high meanwhile researchers are
experimenting with disinfecting masks
with UV light widespread masks use is
expected to continue for years to come
billions and billions more of these are
likely to end up in the ocean unless
people figure out a better way to stay
safe